hi guys I want to do another video on
low salt diet and cholesterol and blood
pressure did you realize that a low salt
diet will actually increase your
cholesterol and triglycerides it's an
interesting it will also lower your
blood pressure but let's take a look at
by how much if you have normal blood
pressure and you go on a low salt diet
it will decrease your blood pressure by
1% very insignificant if you have high
blood pressure and you're gonna low salt
diet it will decrease it by 3.5% again
very insignificant in other words the
data out there and I'll put a link down
below is that a low salt diet is not
significant in protecting the heart
against heart problems at all it's not
significant so all of our attention is
on sodium is bad sodium is bad we need
to reduce sodium but take a look at this
low potassium diets will increase your
risk of high blood pressure increase
your risk of getting a stroke increase
the risk of eating kidney stones but
they don't emphasize that the truth is
that high blood pressure is many times
caused by a potassium deficiency not a
sodium excess so the RDA for sodium is
about 2,300 milligrams yet an average
American will consume about 3300
milligrams of sodium every single day so
that would be an excess of a thousand
milligrams but the RDAs for potassium
per day is 4700 and the average American
consumes only 2,640 giving your
deficiency of 2060 so in reality it's
much more a potassium deficiency than a
sodium excess that's responsible for
high blood pressure so start consuming
more salads you need at least minimally
7 cups of vegetables every single day to
get you close to this requirement
alright thanks for watching hey if
you're interested in finding out the
underlying cause of your body issues
click the link below and take the
evaluation quiz